I think the reason that I was put on this earth was drink little fruity tea
sit in a park and watch the ducks
and I blame capitalism for the reason why I can't do this all time
just kidding I forgot
the problem is
as always old weird men
not even five minutes after I filmed that
some random old guy came and sat next to me
he came to sit down next to me and he was looking at me and like
I'm not delusional
I know exactly what I look like
I just don't want to get a tan line
obviously I'm on guard and I keep catching him look at me and like
you know maybe it's just cause we're the only two people there
I don't know but also there was so much space in the park
he sat down like four feet from me
and then he got a phone call and put his phone up to his ear
pointed directly at me
and like maybe I'm just being paranoid
but I really don't think that I was
but like regardless I just felt unsafe and like that sucked
and it sucks that as women we have to possibly be on guard and can't just like
sit in a parking door
so it's fine I'm fine hanging out with the ducks